I've been telling you for weeks now
about the clear cases of consistently
cringe-worthy corruption and collusion
involving Donald Trump there was the
call involving Argentinian President
Mauricio Macri where allegedly in
addition to congratulations about Donald
Trump's electoral win in the United
States Donald Trump inquired about the
moving forward of a stalled 35-foot real
estate office building project in
Argentina although that was initially
denied the project allegedly started
moving within 72 hours of that phone
call we've talked about Donald Trump
taking advantage of a meeting with
diplomats at his new Washington DC hotel
to say by the way when you come to the
US for state business you can stay at my
hotel we've talked about the blind trust
fiasco where Donald Trump clearly
doesn't even know what a blind trust is
and certainly handing over control of
his businesses to his kids would not be
blind and it would not be a trust and it
is getting even worse starting with a
call involving Donald Trump and Taiwan
now why is this a big deal this is a big
deal because US policy as of 1979 cut
formal relations with Taiwan and it's
very unusual for a u.s. president or
president elect to speak to its high
whinnies leader directly and following
media reports pointing out the risks of
angering China by speaking directly to
Taiwan Donald Trump tweeted quote
interesting how the u.s. sells Taiwan
billions of dollars in military
equipment but I should not accept a
congratulatory call and the history of
this is that China and Taiwan this split
goes back to nineteen forty nine when
the Republic of China government fled
the mainland to Taiwan and in 1971 the
United Nations switched epidemic uh
diplomatic recognition uh to Beijing and
the ROC government was basically forced
out and there's only a handful of
governments currently that even
recognize Taiwan's government and as I
mentioned in 1979 Washington formally
cut diplomatic ties with Taiwan
and they said that that was part of
supporting the one-china concept which
says Taiwan is part of China if you
believe that Taiwan is part of China you
would not have separate diplomatic
relations with two entities Taiwan and
China the sort of makes sense Donald
Trump by having this conversation is
number one ignoring four decades of
protocol but the trumpets will hear that
and they'll say oh good Trump is doing
what he wants he's not a politician is
just an authentic guy he's going a
different direction than everybody else
well there's a few issues with that
number one Donald Trump is trying to
anger China he's threatened with
starting trade wars with China trade
wars that the u.s. can't realistically
win and would be really bad for the
average middle-class American his
economist richard wolf told us last week
but here's the bigger issue and this all
leads us back to corruption and cronyism
weeks before president-elect Donald
Trump's controversial phone call with
the taiwanese president there's a
businesswoman sighing when who claims to
be associated with the Donald Trump
conglomerate who made inquiries about a
major investment in building luxury
hotels as part of Taiwan's new airport
development an official familiar with
the project said that she was associated
with the Trump corporation and she would
like to propose a possible investment
project in the future especially hotels
now this is still unconfirmed Pat the
association of Chen with the Trump
Organization is not confirmed although
she is believed to travel between Taiwan
and the u.s. regularly and in a separate
development and Marie Donahue who
describes herself as the global head of
transient sales and Asia at Trump hotels
was also confirmed to have been in
Taiwan in October so yet again many
Trump supporters backing him on the
platform of going against big business
controlling and being intertwined with
government going against the
establishment going against corruption
and crony capitalism and unfortunately
it seems that yet again crony capitalism
and corruption and kleptocracy is
rearing its ugly head with Donald Trump
well i think too i mean the implication
of Donald Trump speaking to the tiny
time he's president he didn't realize
that it would that would be so
far-reaching analyst yeah maybe he was
just clueless at the at the outside
that's how it was reported yeah but now
when we're learning about these
conflicts of interest stories in the
fact that maybe she's trying to anger
China to get them to the bargaining
table right this could be much worse and
I would argue that if in the if at the
bottom of it there's personal
self-interest of wanting to have these
hotels from which he would make money it
is even even worse but the problem is
that trumps base only cares about
corruption in the way that they care
about Christianity which is if you can
use it in your favor as part of divisive
right-wing politics great if not if
Trump is corrupt or if Trump has lived
his entire life like the opposite of a
biblical Christian then you ignored and
you blame Hillary or Obama or Chuck
Schumer some Democrat and that's that
this is all more of the same send me
your thoughts about this on twitter at d
pakman and also the show is on twitter
at david pakman show make sure you're
following both accounts we'll be back
after this the end of year holiday
season can be sort of a stressful time
for many people and i recently took
advantage of soothe which is a service
that delivers massages to wherever you
are a licensed massage therapist will
show up to your place of work or
business with everything that's
necessary the massage table the linens
the music the oils the lotions the
entire thing you can book your massage
in under 10 seconds on the mobile app or
the website soothe dot-com and this week
my listeners can get thirty dollars
towards their first massage with soothe
soo th e when you enter the code pack
minute check out PA que ma n I tried the
service last week and it's exactly as
described it's so convenient the massage
therapists are super professional and
excellent and to be honest I've I've not
have had many miss experiences with
professional massages mostly because
I've feared that the process is just
incredibly awkward and it actually
wasn't awkward it was really great and
people who know about my tipping
preferences will be
grilled to hear that you don't have to
tip with soothe it's one price it
includes the tip it includes the actual
massage service and it is fantastic so
go to the App Store or Google Play on
iOS or Android search for soothe
download the app or just go to soothe
dot-com soo th e schedule your
appointment and remember promo code
Pakman PA que ma n 4 30 bucks towards
your first massage